[Music]
there's so many aggressive people that
yell at each other but they don't fight
speaking of yelling at each other and
not fighting though does anybody here
hate armenians
no ever had a online troll account
anybody have like uh
in the beginning of the youtube myspace
days
i did because like you know when we had
like our first 10 comments you take it
personally for sure so you would like
start so i'll talk [ __ ] on the main
account and talk [ __ ] on the other
account and then have my fake account
and my real account fall in love with
each other and starting to suck each
other's dicks and it's confused the [ __ ]
out of the other person
it was fun what's your best burn that
you've given from your burner account
i don't remember but i do remember
someone wanted to fight me and joe and
then we replied back like hey meet us at
i think the big lots we gave them like
the crosstalk big lots big lots is a
good spot never replied back dude so
many good fights happen
or kmr or kmart they're just on the
other side of the world not so much
anymore
what's big lots
oh true you could just oh yeah pick and
save pick and save my bad i have troll
accounts now bro
i don't doubt it [ __ ]
what's your username on the troll
account steve uh green owns you and
steve and the crypto king that's okay
that's not even a troll account because
it's you you're like this guy but i was
trolling on it exclusively that's funny
exclusively it's an exclusive troll
just for trolls company credit card yeah
zombie keeps it to just trolling it's a
troll account by definition business i
don't have to pay taxes on it
i found out one of who one of the trolls
were like under um my account oh
really like in person no like i knew who
it was because it was just like in the
beginning when i wasn't even
like when i wasn't getting a lot of
comments yet so i would notice that
comment over and over and over again all
across my social platforms and i was
like who the [ __ ] is this like you're so
obsessed with me
and then one day they were talking [ __ ]
on twitter and then i go to their
account but i looked through their ship
and it was like their old pictures that
they haven't deleted they just changed
their like name
and picture but they still had like
their old tweets
their old pictures and it turned out to
be
my ex's new girlfriend shut the [ __ ] up
i was like i knew it hey what's her name
right now call that busted ass chicken
usually someone that you kind of know
that or the craziest child yeah
i comment on joe's pictures all the time
like for my burner account
[ __ ] yeah
i'm like you're not even 100 japanese i
say something that's like the second
degree over right you would you would
maybe first assume if i was a detective
of this [ __ ] you first assumed maybe
it was your current boyfriend's
ex-girlfriend because it's like somebody
who actually has like a problem with you
if you're a detective you think it's
rick first yeah because when you when
someone gets murdered it's usually
someone very close to them but the truth
or like in my case i have a very
attractive wife i try to keep her
feeling very small oh my god yeah i have
all you troll i have like hundreds of
accounts i do the same strategy too
have you guys ever done that you guys
want you do that for geo no yeah hey you
better feel like [ __ ] about yourself i
do it oh this is the sausage fest this
is yeah yeah
oh no yeah jill will be like oh i'm
feeling really fit as a mom and i'm like
we'll see in two years we'll see
keep her down you know hey getting up
there all right
yep but i have to keep making new
accounts because he's like blocked again
i do hate that now instagram has the
option to
um block the accounts that you've
blocked but
like from the accounts that they've made
um like if they make new accounts yeah
then
you're still blocking them yeah you'll
be blocking them too it's like their ip
address or something that's why you need
a vpn
no idea how that's not fair that's not
fair
i'm trying to continue trolling yeah
yeah okay well this lady right here
says that she can't trust her boyfriend
after reading his disturbing youtube
comments
bro as himself
no so what had happened was
i don't think you could trust anybody if
you took
someone's just out of context someone's
crazy ass comment and then you're like
okay explain this to the world
dude dude i remember one time bart was
yelling at some trolls and he he
basically said
hey [ __ ] you you [ __ ] nazi
the guy was like not saying anything
like anywhere in that realm that was
yours yeah i just say i don't know this
was like two years ago but yeah oh
that's because he used to call everyone
a communist yeah oh yeah he's a
communist too he called him communists
he called him nazis it was [ __ ] great
yeah so
he's dead this woman said she's unable
to trust her boyfriend after discovering
his anonymous youtube profile as he had
posted lewd comments on a video of a
sick woman oh my god hey bro that's wild
holy [ __ ] dude that's crazy
so basically um this this boyfriend
reverse has like a particular dog that
has like distinctive markings on it and
then she was like kind of scrolling uh
through some stuff and then she just um
ended up going onto a youtube video of
this sick woman and then like looking
through comments and there's one
troll-ass comment and she was literally
about to report it for just kind of like
you know being a dick being a [ __ ]
douche right meaning like sexual too
right
more more more
just inappropriate untoward bart's
untoward the tour so
she's about to report it and then she
sees the profile picture and it's a
picture of this dog that has these
really really unique markings just like
that's our dog yeah this is a really
really specific thing and then also
looks at it and what a newbie uploads
his own dog's picture like an idiot and
and a nickname and a nickname that like
he goes by as well
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] what is it is that
quicksilver guy or
it's a video of a woman with a rare skin
condition and he describes her as an
ugly [ __ ] oh my god dude what an ugly
[ __ ] that's so mean
and then also adds further horrible
sexual comments about her so they do get
a little bit more do you have the
comments i don't have the sexual
comments yeah
so wait he calls her ugly [ __ ] and then
he says something sexual to her like is
he
things like nobody wants to [ __ ] your
ass or like like if anybody was ever
going to do you they'd have to put it
back i don't know you know what i mean
this lady better [ __ ] have dumped
this dude
but is it one of those things if you say
it on a british accent it's kind of
funny ah that's true ugly [ __ ] yeah
happy choke on the cork it's sweet it's
kind of like it's a tournament i think
the ugly [ __ ] is still ugly [ __ ] the
[ __ ] one's funny that's for sure it's
just like a call just trying to help
this guy out i'd rather be called an
ugly [ __ ] by a british person for sure
though yeah me too me too
or australian
i feel like they can get away with a lot
i can agree with australia with accents
you know i just feel like it's okay but
if it's an american we're fighting bro
it doesn't feel like offensive at all
yeah yeah it just feels nice it feels
welcoming yeah if they talk [ __ ] like a
british gangster talk [ __ ] i'll be like
dude that's cute but that's also part of
their culture
dude that's cute that's cute man hey man
you hella cute dude when nicki's
filipino grandma starts yelling i'm like
you're so small
how tall is she though it's like 4-1
dude
4-1
crazy how tall are you
um i'm like five one
dude
taller than her if she walked in this
room right now behind bart and she would
shoot you wouldn't even see her
the door would open and close and then
you just hear footsteps you see like the
small top of the head just walking by
you see a little hat
i swear
the funny thing is this chick actually
takes the profile photo sends it to her
boyfriend and it's like hey is this your
dog because it's like uh she's only been
dating they've only been dating for like
five months so i don't think we're going
to go
how are they on the same video that's
the kind of
like there's tons of youtube videos
small world out there it's it's in the
funniest way this is not the first video
that he's commented on so it's for sure
it's his talking nickname troll account
right but what would you do what would
you do what the hell what he'll do
rick's doing this for sure reply and i
go no you're the dumb [ __ ]
right
that's pretty good that's good right
that's probably the only way you could
do handling oh no well i think it
depends on how long the relationship has
been five months if it's five months
i'll be like is this you are you this
type of loser and then just walk away
but if it's like now
i would maybe get him some help
and ask him like really ask me so you're
going to support and talk more [ __ ] so
you can help with him yeah
we're going to get first of all babe
we're getting vpns yeah we if you're
gonna troll you're gonna do it right
you're gonna do it right correctly
we're changing your profile photo let's
switch up the user account get a vpn
if you're gonna be a troll be a troll
correctly that's what i mean that's a
real life partner you know that's pretty
cool no but i feel like these trolls are
like genuinely like really sick in the
head yeah so it's like if it's my
partner and he i find that he's doing
these things i feel like
if i could help i would you know like
therapy that's a really mature answer
yeah you're that was incredibly mature
very profound
maybe we just been hanging around each
other way too much i thought we were on
one page here what if you went on your
favorite pornhub video yes and you see
on the comments and then rick was like
i'd pay to bust my loads in your eye oh
he's already doing that oh okay
that's not new
that didn't sound that crazy to me yeah
that's true what like your favorite
point of view he's like hey
if you need help hit me up i can save
you from this
oh wow we already do do that come on
what a great couple
i think also for you then it's hard to
like cross the line with you then right
what do you mean so like since your
threshold is high because some chicks
might be like
or whatever you know but then i think
for you it's like oh we already do that
he already busted my eye and my butt and
my nose and my ear so it's really hard
to offend you so it's like you have a
really nice threshold so it would take
rick to do something crazy and it's also
just like communication we're very open
and honest with each other
in on every single level so it gives us
that freedom to really
be open and be ourselves fact that you
just said yes to what he said is why
you're so understanding yeah
yeah that was actually really cool what
about this
you open rick's refrigerator and there's
eyeballs in a jar whoa okay good what
kind
like human
she's like cat eyeballs easy yeah sir
we're asian because human ones yeah
they're yummy dude are they for sorcery
or you open up his laptop and he's
leaving comments on other vietnamese
chefs and he's like your food's better
than my girls
oh that's over it's done
down the line found the threshold found
it
rick stop bro we still had a search for
it though you know or does he hate would
he hate on you with like things that he
wants he's like this [ __ ] better make
some pizza next
bbq
[Laughter]
i know 81 up votes it's like oh [ __ ]
dude yeah you have to
let's see if she could really make some
mojo potatoes
no way she can replicate the wrestling i
know right
you have a craving she can make fur but
how about mojo potatoes
[Music]
you